I think people have to be very careful
to not get trapped along the way with
things that you can afford with your
current lifestyle like the way you're
living and the way you're earning but
they're also imprisoning you in the fact
that you are now going to have to work
this 40-hour week job in order to get
this thing that you can't afford but now
you're saddled down to this job you've
no you're not saving you're not you're
not putting things in a good place and
you're working for these things working
for things as rewards is a real trap
that a lot of people fall into it's the
biggest one you know that's even telev
also says that uh you know there are two
great addictions heroin and a monthly
salary
right and and that's why you can't get
rich renting out your time because even
when you start charging more and more
for your time it's a slow upgrade Loop
and then you upgrade your house at the
same time and open your car at the same
time you move in the neighborhood you
really also have to get used to ignoring
your peers
or upgrading or changing the definition
of your peers a lot of people here who
are poor here but they would be rich if
they were living in Thailand and Bali
and if they have the luxury of a
remotely doable job they may want to be
living there and saving up money but the
ignoring the peers is an issue because
the Keeping Up With the Jones is a real
phenomenon yeah Envy makes the world go
around right yeah
and then there's a there's a other thing
that people have to avoid even allowing
their mind to think when they're hearing
what you're saying and all this logical
fantastic advice there's these six dirty
words that's easy for you to say yeah
that is a terrible trap I mean look I
grew up as a first generation immigrant
uh in Jamaica Queens uh with zero money
single mom two kids working day and
night going to school uh you know I wash
dishes uh I was K I was working catering
jobs I was mowing lawns I was working
since the age of 11 on and off here and
there
um didn't have two cents to rub together
you know I had to borrow 400 to go to
college like literally a short four
hundred dollars 400 I had to find 400 I
didn't have it you know got rejected
from a job at Dunkin Donuts so like okay
it's not to say that it's easy it's not
easy it's not actually really freaking
in heart it is the hardest thing you
will do but it's also the rewarding
thing you know look at the kids who are
born rich no meaning to their lives
you're a terrible Place yeah your real
your real resume is just a cataloging of
all your suffering right if I were to
ask you to describe your real life to
yourself when you look back in your
deathbed you're going to go back and say
what are the interesting things I've
done and it's all going to be around the
sacrifices that you've made and the hard
things that you did anything you're
given doesn't matter you know you you
have your four limbs you have your brain
you have your head you have your skin
that's all for granted so you have to do
hard things anyway to create your own
meaning in life
um making money is a fine one yeah
struggle it is hard I'm not going to say
it's easy it's a really hard but the
tools are all available it's all there
there's also these these traps that
people sort of establish in their own
mind of giving themselves excuses or
giving themselves in unsurmountable
obstacles insurmountable
paths to victim mentality yeah yeah it's
somebody else's fault it's my skin
color's fault it's the system's fault
yeah those people are sinking I feel bad
for them I want to shake them out of it
and say actually you can get out of it
you just have to stop thinking it's
everybody you have to alter the
perspective yeah but it's so difficult
for people to do it's one of the most
difficult things for people to do is to
change the way they approach approach
reality itself
at the end of the day I I do think even
despite what I said earlier life is
really a single player game it's all
going on in your head you know whatever
you think you believe will very much
shape your reality both from what risks
you take and what actions you perform
but also just your everyday experience
of reality if you're walking down the
street and you're judging everyone
you're like I don't like that person
because their skin color I don't like
that oh she's she's not attractive that
guy's fat this person's a loser oh who
put this in my way uh you know the more
you judge the more you're gonna separate
yourself and you'll feel good for an
instant because you'll feel good about
yourself I'm better than that but then
you're gonna feel lonely and then you're
just gonna see negativity everywhere the
world just reflects your own feelings
back at you reality is neutral
the reality has no judgments to a tree
there's no concept of right or wrong or
good or bad right you're born you have a
whole set of sensory experiences and
stimulations and lights and colors and
sounds and then you die yeah and how you
choose to interpret that is up to you
you do have that choice so this is what
I meant that happiness is a choice if
you believe it's the choice then you can
start working on it and I can't tell you
how to find it because it's your own
conditionings that are making you
unhappy so you have to uncondition
yourself it's just like I can't fix your
eating habits for you can give you some
general guidelines but you got to go
through the hard habit forming of How to
Eat Right but you have to believe it's
possible and it is absolutely possible I
was miserable I'm happy as a clam it's
not just the money I got there before
the money
Peter Thiel talks a lot about how
competition is besides the point it's
counterproductive we're highly memetic
creatures we copy what everybody else is
doing around us we copy our desires from
them everyone around me is a great
artist I want to be an artist if
everyone around me is a great business
person I want to be a business person
everybody around me is a social activist
I want to be a social activist that's
where my self-esteem will come from you
have to be a little careful when you get
caught up in these status games that you
end up competing over things that aren't
worth competing over so Peter Thiel
talks about how he was going to be a law
clerk because he was in law school and
everybody around him wanted to be a law
clerk for a Supreme Court Justice or
some famous judge and he got rejected
and that's what made him go into
business so it helped him break out of a
lesser game into a greater game so
sometimes you just get trapped in the
wrong game because you're competing and
the best way to escape competition to
get away from the Specter of competition
which is not just stressful and
nerve-wracking but will often drive you
to just the wrong answer the way to
Escape competition is to just be
authentic to yourself if you are
fundamentally building and marketing
something that is just an extension of
who you are no one can compete with you
on that
but when people look at particularly
social media let's bring back to that
when you see someone who you know you
see them posed in front of their mansion
with their beautiful car and they're
leaning against it with their designer
clothes on their expensive watch you go
ah I want that right that's what I want
what you really want is freedom you want
freedom from your money problems right
and I think that's okay so people once
someone can solve their money problems
either by lowering their lifestyle or by
making enough money and you know
essentially what you want to get
everybody to is retirement but not
retirement in the I'm 65 years old
sitting in a nursing home collecting a
check retirement different definition
retirement is when you stop sacrificing
today for some imaginary tomorrow
okay yes when today is complete in and
of itself you're retired yeah and so how
do you get there well one is you can
have so much money saved up that just
your passive income off of that without
your having to lift a finger covers your
burn rate keep your burn rate low right
a second is you just drive your burn
rate down to zero you become a monk a
third is you're doing something you love
you enjoy it so much it's not about the
money right so there are multiple ways
to that path but the most common is
people just say I need to make more
money and the kind of wealth creation
that I talk about is about creating
Timeless principles and adapting
yourselves that making money won't be an
issue
anybody who's read your life you're a
testament to the idea that to not be a
victim but to be a Survivor and it's an
attitude that has helped me in my short
life so far could you perhaps expand on
that idea how it's helped you and how
that is perhaps one of the greatest ways
to live your life out regardless of what
happens of course
feeling like it's really interesting to
make change some people are victimized
by other people
and if it weren't for the ending nation
that that causes we wouldn't have
reforms that we need
but that truth is mixed with another
very counterproductive or an individual
to feel like a victim even if he is
best attitude is just to be careful
about everything and keep plugging along
and therefore I don't like politicians
that get ahead by trying to make
everybody else feel like a victim
yeah
they make my flesh crawl
and
I just don't believe in it of course
who wants to be a victim instead of a
survivor
of course we want and but
feeling like a victim you can recognize
your position as bad and try and improve
it that's okay but to have a deep
feeling of
the wooden that's all somebody else's
fault is a very counterproductive Way To
Think
people aren't even like being around it
it's really stupid and yet our
politicians build on it and make their
careers work by doing something that's
very bad for all what people are talking
to and they think they're doing the
world's work you know it's crazy it's
absolutely crazy reflections
working for things as rewards the things
you own end up owning you Chuck palahnuk
the goal isn't passive income the goal
is active income doing what you like
sahil Lavinia I recommend watching the
video that by Kapil Gupta which Naval
recently shared on Twitter you can check
the link at the top right corner of the
screen the victim mentality my formula
for greatness is amorphati that one
wants nothing to be different not
forward not backwards not in all
eternity not merely bear what is
necessary still less conceal it but love
it nature a great man is hard on himself
a small man is hard on others Confucius
the competition trap if you have a
guaranteed Market of one I.E yourself
you are ahead of 99 of all entrepreneurs
out there team in fairies ideas don't
come out fully formed they only become
clearer as you work on them you just
have to get started Mark Zuckerberg
something that has been useful to me is
this idea of building something that I
myself would love to consume even if I
see other entrepreneurs already
executing on that same concept I just do
something similar or shamelessly copycat
them if they have better ideas this
might look like I'm getting into
competition instead of escaping from it
but the thing is that as I execute the
project I naturally give it my own spin
over time so when I just start the
project my idea it's also just starting
it is far from being a complete business
idea but as I work on the project the
idea gets more and more formed and as it
gets formed you're slowly getting away
from competition until the ideal
scenario in which there is demand for
your product and the market cannot find
it anywhere where else other than
through you that's the point where you
become a personal Monopoly as one of my
favorite writers David Pearl would put
it thanks for watching